one of the most important theorems that
the sas congruency condition helps us to
prove is the isosceles triangle theorem
before we move on to proving it we need
to know what it exactly is
look at the triangle abc
these two sides are equal
let's move the triangle to the left to
understand the theorem
the theorem tells us that if side ac
equals side a b
that is if this side equals this side
then measure of angle abc will also be
equal to that of angle acb
this angle which is opposite to this
side will be equal to this angle which
is opposite to side a b
if the two sides in a triangle are equal
then the angles opposite them are also
equal
how do we prove this
let's move on to a new page
we redraw triangle abc and jot down all
the data we have
lengths of these two sides are equal as
it's an isosceles triangle
the first thing we should do before we
prove something is write down all the
data that has been given to us
we have been given that segment ac is
congruent to segment a b
the next thing we have to note down is
that we have been asked to prove
we have to prove that the angles
opposite the equal sides in a triangle
are congruent
that is we need to prove that angle abc
is congruent to angle acb
looking at the figure you would feel
that we haven't been provided with any
data
then how are we supposed to prove these
two angles equal the best way to prove
any two angles or any two sides
congruent is by proving two triangles
congruent
so they become corresponding angles and
will hence be congruent
but here we have just one triangle and
we need to prove these two angles
congruent
in such cases we make two triangles
we can do a bit of construction to help
ourselves
let's draw the angle bisector of angle
bac
we are talking about this angle
so we draw the bisector like this
let this red dotted line be the angle
bisector of angle bac and let it
intersect bc at point d
measure of angle bad will equal that of
angle c a d
now we have two triangles
triangle abd
and triangle acd
if we somehow managed to prove that two
sides and an included angle of triangle
abd are equal to the corresponding two
acd
then we can say that the two triangles
are congruent
after we have jotted down the data given
and the two proof section
we go to the proof
we have to look at triangle abd and
triangle acd
have we been given any data about the
two triangles
yes we have been given that segment a b
is congruent to segment ac
based on our construction we can also
say that angle bad is congruent to angle
cad
now this is interesting
we can see that this side is common to
both the triangles
we can say that segment a d is congruent
to segment a d since it is the common
side
guess what we just proved that the two
sides and the included angles of both
the triangles are equal
side angle side
we can say that triangle abd is
congruent to triangle acd by the sas
axiom
this in turn tells us that angle abc is
congruent to angle acb since they are
corresponding angles of congruent
triangles
we proved these two angles congruent
we use the side angle side axiom to
prove the isosceles triangle theorem
which says that angles opposite equal
sides are always equal